here's a brand new idea from the United
States which can turn your television
set into a game that two can play a gem
play Poong first released in 1972 was as
simple as a game can possibly be two
white rectangles batting a square bowl
back and forward as players attempted to
win points off each other
it tested reflexes and nerves and
introduced an exciting new medium to
millions most importantly it turned pal
against pal
or sibling against sibling in a spot of
friendly or fierce competition that's
something the gaming industry is still
doing to the delight of millions to this
day video games have come a long way
since pong though your mother thinks
you'll be spending more time at your
homework what do you think about that
miss old stereotype of gamers being
isolated loners is quite frankly boring
and outdated video games have long since
come out of the bedroom and into the
world shared and celebrated by fans and
communities across the globe here are
six more of the iconic titles that
helped make that happen around five
years after pong space invaders was
launched bringing with it more colors
more sophisticated music and a
distinctive plot and mood while skeptics
dismissed pong as a passing novelty
space invaders proved that video games
were not only here to stay but they were
a massive and extremely profitable
global industry and the little pixelated
enemies are still used to this day as an
icon of videogames as a whole Wacka
Wacka his way onto the scene in 1980
pac-man was arguably video gaming's
first real character urban legend states
that his shape was inspired by a pizza -
a couple of slices pac-man tried
something different in it you had to use
your wits and strategically evade
enemies until you were strong enough to
chase them down instead pac-man quickly
became a pop-culture phenomenon
featuring on t-shirts ties glasses bags
balloons board games books caps
the other merchandise that sat around in
one spot for too long of all the
videogame characters to grace our
consoles over the years
none have made an impact quite like
Mario the side-scrolling platformer game
featured a plumber trying to rescue a
princess from a fire-breathing turtle
and a labyrinth of pipes and platforms
to traverse while avoiding razor-toothed
to plants and even order looking
mushrooms and so of course it captured
gamers hearts and became one of the
fastest selling video games of all time
Tomb Raider was the butt-kicking
action-adventure game that sold
PlayStation consoles by the bucketload
and introduced the world to fictional
archeologist slash treasure hunter Lara
Croft as one of the first ever new
double female game protagonists Lara's
launch in 1996 had already caused a
media sensation if pac-man was gaming's
first-ever character and Mario its first
mascot Lara Croft was its first icon but
you could argue that Lara is really more
a source of male titillation than female
empowerment but she was one of the first
playable women i remember seeing in a
video game and that representation
really mattered world of warcraft
launched in 2004 still stands as one of
the biggest massively multiplayer online
role-playing games of all time players
could create an avatar assign them a
class race and skills and then send them
out into the world of Azeroth to explore
complete quests and meet with other
player characters in its prime the game
had more than 100 million registered
users world of warcraft played a huge
role in legitimizing multiplayer gaming
for the masses and I should know I spent
six years on it minecraft is an
open-world game that lets players build
create and alter environments by making
placing and destroying blocks it's been
extremely popular with children and
academics alike due to its incredible
scope for creating physics and logic
based puzzles and to
scale replicas of everything from the
Starship Enterprise to the British Isles
a large part of its popularity is that
it's an incredibly social game with a
litany of devoted fans who work together
to build entire worlds but of little
colored blocks of course there were many
other titles that changed the world over
gaming's long and lustrous history in
the last decade the rise of indie games
eSports and mobile games have changed
the gaming landscape again as players
themselves diversify and look for new
experiences they can share with other
players fans have known this for a long
time but video games aren't just games
they're art they're fun they're
beautiful make animes delight teach
empathize and part they're a huge part
of our culture and they're here to
change the world thanks for watching
don't forget to subscribe and click the
bail to receive notifications for new
videos see you again soon